Kesava peels are byproducts of cassava
processing recognized as a potential
feed resource but wasted constituting a
major environmental nuisance within and
around processing centers due to drying
constraints traditionally drying is done
on bare floor over a period of two to
three days in the dry season to get a
marketable product peels dried in this
manner are not marketed at their
potential prices due to quality concerns
relating to contamination by aflatoxins
as well as poor storability due to
improper drying as a result farmers and
the feed industry do not have access to
processed peels of desired quality in
sufficient quantities in 2015 CGIAR
scientists working in its research
programs on roots tubers and bananas
humid tropics and livestock and fish
developed an innovative processing
method that reduces drying time to six
to eight hours
yielding high-quality products that
could be used to feed ruminants and mono
gastrics there is every indication that
processed peels of high quality are in
great demand from the feed industry as
such this provides an opportunity to
mitigate feed scarcity while cassava
peel processors who adopt the innovation
are able to generate additional income
there is thus a potential to convert
millions of tons of an environmental
problem into a valuable resource for
food production and in doing so also
create a new industry that offers new
income and employment to participants in
cassava processing 80% of whom are women
this video explains how to achieve the
best results from this innovation
cassava peels use for processing should
be free from contamination stumps large
woody tubers soil and other foreign
materials must be removed from peels
before grating to protect the rasp ER
from damage
fresh cassava peels should always be
used as stored peels begin to ferment
and become soggy and slippery which
makes them difficult to grate once
sorted the peels are grated to reduce
the particle size to facilitate deep
watering and drying peels are harder to
grate than tubers so they have to be
grated three times to achieve the
desired size grated peels must then be
packed in plastic woven bags in small
quantities of 8 to 12 kilograms the bags
are then folded halfway and neatly
stacked one above the other in a metal
frame for pressing a desirable stacking
height leaves sufficient room for
inserting a hydraulic jack wooden planks
which ensure the uniform distribution of
pressure are used to separate the
stacked bags and the hydraulic jack
application of pressure through the jack
results in rapid water loss dewatering
results in water loss of almost 50
percent by weight of the starting
material
press bags are then allowed to stand
overnight to ferment the result is an
intermediate product the cassava peel
cake with a 38 to 42 percent moisture
content wet cassava peeled cake can be
fed as is to cattle sheep goats and pigs
it can be stored for seven days without
spoiling and thus could be transported
and marketed over long distances within
that period to produce dried mash
intermediate cassava peel cake is
loosened by grating to improve the
granularity of the material and improve
its flow through a sieve
sealing separates the loosened cake into
a fine fraction lower in fiber higher
and energy content from a coarse
fraction higher and fibre lower in
energy content resulting in fine and
coarse mash process mash is then dried
six to eight hours by spreading on
commonly available surfaces for example
concrete slabs and plastic or metal
sheeting on rainy days the saved
material can be toasted in a metal pan
once dried or toasted the material
should be between 10 to 12 percent
moisture and can be bagged and stored
for a period of four to six months
without any spoilage flash drying is
also an option in the industrial case it
is important to remember that all
machines and processing areas must be
kept clean hygienic conditions are
imperative to prevent fungal
contamination and ensure quality
three major high-quality cassava peeled
products are created by this process wet
cassava cake for cattle sheep goat and
pig feed that has a shelf life of one
week dried fine mash which is suitable
for poultry pigs and fish dried coarse
mash also for cattle sheep goats and
pigs the dried high-quality cassava peel
mash products have a long shelf life of
between four and six months processors
can choose an appropriate drying option
depending on weather conditions and the
facilities available to them